I'm living in Tampa Heights which is
right next to ebore city in Tampa right
so this is all these are all like little
suburbs of Tampa and they're all built
back in the
1920s right 1890s 1910s 1920 so I'm I've
I bought this 8un building I renovated
it into a Triplex I mean I'm driving an
Audi I'm dating a a a woman that I
should not have been dating I mean I
don't know what she was thinking um um
so I'm you know I'm we going on
vacations like everything Life's good so
but every once in a while you know like
we're you know we're things happen you
get a phone call hey this is what just
happened and I one time I got a phone
call from same broker Kelly Kelly calls
me up and said listen we got a problem
this
was I want to say this was Allan Duncan
this was one of the first ones that I
had done right we used them but uh and
so he so she calls me up and says
listen
Allan Duncan never made his first
mortgage payment and I had a friend of
mine or one of my
codefendants when we
closed on that
loan we both got checks for whatever 40
or 50 Grand keep in mind we're also
buying some of this money is going into
a business account we're buying property
we're so it's not like I'm pocketing
hundreds of thousands of dollars or even
you know even 20 or $30,000 on every
closing I'm more like I'm getting 25 10
20 and this guy's getting 10 and this
guy's getting 15 and then we're to
taking 60 and we're putting it into the
business account we're buying a bunch of
vacant Lots or we're building some new
houses we're trying to kind of take all
this and turn it into a development
company um but we still have to pay our
bills so you know my buddy's got to go
to he's got to go to Amsterdam at least
for two weeks you know right he's from
Belgium that's you apparently have to do
that at least once a year so uh he he
was so when I gave him his check the
check I said
look you're going to make the Pay Here's
like 20 grand or 15 grand but you got to
make the payments on this thing for the
next six months he go no problem I said
okay so she calls me up a month and a
half later and says hey um Allan Duncan
did not did not make his first payment
and I went uh oh my God and I I and he
was actually renting the apartment
downstairs for me so I run downstairs
and I open the door and I go bro I'm
like did you make Duncan's payment and
he turns around he's like is it do and I
was like oh my God so I run back you
know I grabb the phone I'm like he
didn't make it he didn't make it she's
like okay well here's what's happening
the account executive is calling they've
got the file and it was called was
southstar Bank southstar bank has it
they reviewed it they've already been
ordering documents they they they're
saying that this guy there there's a
problem they are it's it's it's falling
apart like the whole thing's falling
they they know something's wrong but
they don't know exactly what it's just
just something suspicious that she
didn't tell me that on the phone okay
like she she's saying there's something
wrong they're freaking out yeah because
the account executive didn't really know
she just got a phone call saying hey
have you ever met this this broker did
she meet the guy who is the guy he
hasn't paid we're calling the cell
nobody's answering and really most of
this was was my buddy Rudy's fault he's
just not doing any of this stuff any of
the things he's supposed to be doing so
we go to the office and I call South
allar Bank uh I get the secretary and I
said look I need to talk to whatever the
guy the big guy was it was one of them
was like the president and one was like
the somebody else anyway vice president
so I said I need to talk to so and so
the vice president and she says I'm
sorry he's in a business meeting I said
well listen tell him this is Alan Duncan
like you need to go tell him is Alan
Duncan's on the phone right now I'm
assure you he wants to talk to me and
she's like all right hold on and I mean
like 20 seconds lat you know speaker
phone hey Mr uh Mr Duncan uh this is so
and so and uh you know I'm here with the
uh with our lawyer and the president of
the bank and our head of fraud we were
just discussing you and I was like okay
um I understand that you guys are uh I
haven't made my first payment I said it
actually came back in the mail I had the
wrong address that was completely my
fault and I apologize I said but I can
get you a cashier's check today I will
overnight it no problem hope that's
going to be okay I say said way we're
way past that way past that I said okay
um what's what's the issue and they were
like I mean look to be honest I don't
think I'm talking to Allan Duncan I
don't think there is an allen Duncan
he's like I mean your social security
number was issued a couple years ago um
the we called the bank um and and this
was I we had gone with like south or Sun
Trust Bank right so it was a real Bank
MH so it wasn't our normal bank and they
called they don't they don't have any
record of you and I was like well I've
never been happy with southstar bank
there if you know it sounds like a
banking error um and they're and they're
like yeah I don't think this isn't cute
he says I don't think I'm talking to
Alan Duncan right now right and you were
Terri terrified but you have to be
playing it cool I guess I mean I know
what am I going to say no you're talking
to Matt Cox like I can't say that like
I'm just got to keep running with it
just like okay well look you know and
he's like you know we called the DMV
this you know
they don't have a list for you in the in
the you know in their website uh we
think that the uh you know we don't
think you exist yeah you know we're
still waiting for a phone call back from
who so so and so and so and so and I'm
just like oh my God and I said um have
you called have you called the
authorities yet and they were like no we
haven't but once we put our file
together we will and then the head of
the fraud department they said oh by the
way Mr I forget his name but the head of
the fraud department is worked for the
FBI for like 10 years or something or 12
years and I and so I mean I'm just like
and by the way the appra the broker is
there MH and my buddy Rudy is there and
I mean they're he's pacing the room
she's in tears crying like there and I'm
like okay well fellas I say where's this
headed where's this going what are we
doing and and they so they're they're
kind of chuckling and joking about it
and I remember being like thinking
what's the deal
like it's weird and I said look why
don't I
just let me just pay you back M they
said ah well we we'll get the money
we're not worried about I said you don't
seem worried about the money about
getting any the money back like don't
why don't you just let me I'll cut you a
check I can get you the money back like
what do I I owed them like 150 or
something I forget exactly it was
nothing I'm like I ow you 150,000 let me
c a check for
150,000 and they were like no no you
know that's uh uh we'll get the money
back when we foreclose on the property
and that's what I was like like
oh they think the property is worth like
$195,000 or something and I went oh I
said I understand okay I said do you
have the appraisal in front of you and
they were like yeah and I said open it
up I said take a look at comp number one
that's owned by a guy named you know Lee
black comp number two you know is owned
by you know whatever David silver
whatever the names were and I'm like you
know like black silver red I said I am
all those people and I said let me tell
you what I've done and I tell them just
lay it out boom boom boom boom
boom I said so you can call the FBI but
you're not going to get all your money
back or you can let me give you your
money
back and we can let this we let sleeping
dogs lie the whole thing goes away I
apologize you know I had every intention
of making all the payments it's a glitch
you caught me no my bad and so these
guys are just like oh my God like now
they're they put me on hold they're
looking through the file they come back
and I remember at some point we go back
forth back forth and finally they come
back and they said listen you still have
the money I said yeah well first they
come back they threaten me oh well when
the F we give us to the FBI you I said
that's not true I said the money was
deposited into a bank account it has
since been moved the bank account bank
account has been closed it's been
removed in cash that money is gone you
will never see that money I will be
cutting you if I pay you back at all
it'll be from another account mhm and so
the FBI agent ends up saying he's right
even if we caught him red-handed the
likelihood that any of these funds will
be ever be recouped is is zero like
there's almost no money's ever recouped
and so we end up um they put me on hold
again they come back and they go how
quickly can you get us a cashier
check and I go like that day I go get
them a cash cashier check overnight the
cashiers check they never called the FBI
they never did anything now at that
point we actually ditched that whole
that uh James or Allan Duncan I remember
at that point we went to the mall ran up
all the credit cards and just threw
everything away and walked away because
it was shot you know that whole that guy
was shot I think we borrowed whatever
$800,000 or 900,000 in his name so with
the banks it's really really all about
the money that listen when I go on the
run I got one where I was caught so
red-handed
it's it's insane how how bad it was and
and listen that's not that's nothing I I
got caught by um uh Washington Mutual
one time I was caught by Washington
Mutual where we had done six owner
occupied
duplexes so if you say you're going to
live in a house you can get about 95%
financing but if it's an investment
property you got to put down 20% you get
about 80% financing so
a buddy of mine who was a sheriff's
deputy we had his wife
by I'm going to say six owner occupied
duplexes saying she lived in every
single one of
them well you can't owner occupy six
dwellings like it that's
fraud now granted her W2s and pay subs
were correct but she didn't put the down
payments down even the down payments we
didn't put down we actually got cash
back but months later we the they called
the a lawyer
from um Washington Mutual ends up
calling uh the mortgage broker and
saying that they ended up with two of
the owner occupied duplexes
because Washington Mutual had a credit
line extended to one of the lenders
who'd lend the money so it actually was
Washington Mutual so it was a couple
months later when they went to sell sell
it in a you know they packaged them
together and sell them they realize we
have the same customer with two duplexes
side by side both owner occupied this is
fraud so she comes in she tells me oh my
gosh this lawyer's on the phone this is
what happened I'm like oh wow this is
horrible I end up getting on the phone
with him we have a huge we have a
conversation and I'm like you know he's
like look you know this is a big deal we
could call the FBI I'm like look who
knows who was involved in this maybe
somebody on your side was involved maybe
somebody on my side I don't know what my
mortgage broker did I'll deal with her
on my own why don't you just let us
refinance the properties not only did we
talk him into refin let allowing us to
refinance the properties he gave us a
reduced um a reduced balance of what we
owed him because we couldn't we couldn't
borrow enough to pay them off so they
took like a $220,000 hit just to
refinance those properties never called
the FBI never did any was absolutely
fraud I had I had a broker one time we
got with over a million dollar in loans
that he had done that were
fraudulent Pinnacle Bangor which was out
of Chicago the owner called me and he
was like look your mortgage broker did
this like there was a bunch of uh
canceled checks they were fake canceled
checks so they looked like they had run
through the bank for the somebody's
rent but they hadn't does that make
sense like you pay your rent they
deposit it it goes to the bank and
they've got all the numbers and
everything well I had a bunch that were
blank that all you had to do was fill
out your your borrower information and
then you cut and pasted his full his
name and his address at the upper
leftand corner you make a copy of it it
looks like canceled checks we had 24 of
them well my one of my Brokers was using
them for all of his files like even if
the person really had a rental history
he didn't want to order it he just did
this it was easier it's faster yeah yeah
just an idiot wow so they catch a
million dollars worth of loans they call
me up and then they caught another
million dollar but they had already sold
them to Household Bank so while I'm on
the phone with the the owner his name is
Gary and we're talking he's like look
this is what we found this is this this
is what happened and I remember I said
um Gary at the end of this conversation
if you think I'm cutting you a check for
a million dollars I said just don't have
it you don't have it this was when I
owned the mortgage company and he says
uh no I what I'm I'm asking you for your
word that if any of
these come back on us they're in Florida
they're in your area you'll help us get
rid of the properties you'll we'll
foreclose we're going to have to resell
them I don't want to be flying down
there just help us get rid of them I
said absolutely of course no problem I
said what about the I said well what are
you going to do with them he goes well
they're going to be a part of a a
package like a $3 million package we're
selling to Household Bank the other ones
they had caught had already been sold
the ethical thing to
do is to contact Household Bank say we
will buy those back we are going to take
care of it's not what happened in fact
Gary flew down a couple weeks later took
me and several of the Brokers not that
broker but several of the Brokers out to
dinner had a few drinks and he openly
admitted he's like look I don't care if
all the loans have fraud in them as long
as they don't come back on me that's
what I'm concerned about because there's
a a clawback clause for one year he's
like so if they can perform for one year
I don't
care that was it how many people in the
industry do you think are operating like
this um and by like this I mean in the
aforementioned gray
area I would say there was probably
after like the like after the 2008
financial crisis I would say it cleaned
up
considerably but I would say at this
point it's it's just as bad as it ever
was and and keep in mind these a lot of
the loans that caused
uh the
problems were like you know they called
them liar loans or or um you know you
know no no qualification like no qual
loans right no
income um well those loans are they
exist again like there are subprime
companies that are doing that again they
don't I don't think they call them
subprime anymore they call them so they
got some other name yeah rebranded yeah
they've rebranded a little bit but it's
it's happening all over again
it just seems the whole the whole real
estate SL banking system is very prone
to this kind of corruption I mean but
but how how can you fix it like if
if a lot of the things they fixed a lot
of the manipulation they' fixed but if
you tighten it too much then the average
person can't get a loan like you you you
so you you know and and the thing is
some of these loans sometimes changing a
W2
you know should that person have gotten
in that into that house no he shouldn't
have he didn't qualify um but he makes
all of his payments so it's like is it a
fraudin loan yeah but it performs so you
know I think that I would say that I
forget what the FBI statistic was it was
like 20% or 30% prior to the 2000 prior
to the the financial crisis was like 20
or 30% of like bank loans they were
saying contained some kind of fraud even
if it was just a lie you know if you
want to cut 30% out of the out of the
you know that that's a ton that's a
ton